As coronavirus cases continue to surge across the United States, parents, teachers, and school officials are looking warily toward the beginning of the 2020 school year. With many openings just a few weeks away, will children return to physical classrooms, or will they log into classes via Zoom? Or will it be some combination of both? These questions have touched off emotional debates among parents, health officials, school systems, teachers, unions, and other groups. It's become a political flashpoint, too. President Trump has threatened to withhold funding from schools that choose not to bring kids back to classrooms, even as major school systems across the country are announcing plans to start the school year online. Schools must weigh the health risks of reopening buildings against the educational risks of keeping them closed.
随着新冠病毒病例在美国各地持续激增，家长、教师和学校官员都在忧心忡忡地展望2020学年的开始。距离许多学校开学仅剩几周时间，孩子们是会回到实体教室，还是通过Zoom登录课堂？又或者两者兼而有之？这些问题在家长、卫生官员、学校系统、教师、工会和其他群体之间引发了激烈的情绪化辩论。这也已成为一个政治焦点。特朗普总统威胁要扣留那些选择不让孩子回到教室的学校的资金，尽管全国各地的主要学校系统都在宣布在线开启新学年的计划。学校必须权衡重新开放校园的健康风险与保持关闭带来的教育风险。
Psychological research can offer tools to help schools minimize harm and make the best decisions possible under these difficult circumstances. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Heidi Schwann Gruber, a developmental psychologist and director of the National Academy of Sciences Board on Science Education. She and her colleagues released a report July 15th offering guidance on how K-12 schools can weigh the risks and benefits of reopening. They gathered research from epidemiologists, social and behavioral scientists, and experts in public health and education. Their conclusion was that schools should prioritize reopening for students in grades K-3-5 and those with special needs.
心理学研究可以提供工具，帮助学校在这些困难情况下尽量减少伤害并做出尽可能最好的决定。欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），该节目旨在探索心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是海蒂·施万·格鲁伯（Heidi Schwann Gruber）博士，她是发展心理学家，也是美国国家科学院科学教育委员会的主任。她和同事们在7月15日发布了一份报告，为K-12学校如何权衡重新开放的风险与收益提供了指导。他们收集了来自流行病学家、社会和行为科学家以及公共卫生和教育领域专家的研究成果。他们的结论是，学校应优先考虑让K-3-5年级的学生以及有特殊需求的学生返校。
Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Schwain Gruber. Thank you so much. It's great to be here. So as I just said, the top-line conclusion you came to in the report is that schools should prioritize reopening for the youngest students, K-3-5, and those with special needs. How did you come to that conclusion and what evidence did you base that conclusion on? So the committee recognized that fundamentally the decision to reopen is a very complex one that involves weighing risks. And the primary sets of risks are the public health risks from the virus and exposure to the virus against the educational risks and the risks to families and communities of keeping school buildings closed. And the committee actually was very careful to say school buildings closed because we made the assumption that as schools did in spring 2020, they provided virtual and distance learning options that the same will happen in the coming school year if schools don't open for in-person learning. So essentially the risks were public health risks against the educational risks if kids aren't getting in-person instruction and if families can't benefit from the services that's.
欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，施万·格鲁伯博士。非常感谢。很高兴来到这里。正如我刚才所说，你们在报告中得出的核心结论是，学校应优先考虑让最年幼的学生（K-3-5年级）和有特殊需求的学生返校。你们是如何得出这一结论的？又是基于什么证据？委员会认识到，从根本上说，重新开放的决定是一个非常复杂的决策，涉及风险权衡。主要的风险权衡在于病毒带来的公共卫生风险和接触病毒的风险，与保持学校建筑关闭对教育、家庭和社区造成的风险。委员会非常谨慎地使用了“学校建筑关闭”这一表述，因为我们假设，正如2020年春季学校所做的那样，如果学校不开放线下教学，它们会提供虚拟和远程学习选项，未来学年也会发生同样的情况。因此，本质上，风险权衡是公共卫生风险与孩子们无法获得线下教学以及家庭无法从学校提供的服务中受益所带来的教育风险之间的较量。
schools give in person. So then the question was, if kids are going to be experiencing distance learning rather than in person, which kids benefit most or least from distance learning? So who is at greatest risk when you're seeing distance learning happen over a long period of time? So that required really turning to the developmental psychology literature and what we know about kids of different ages and how they learn and the kinds of supports that they need. So the committee looked at broadly what we know about development and what we know about academic development, cognitive development, as well as socio-emotional development for kids of different ages, and what we know about modes of distance learning and particularly virtual learning, because we assume that's a lot of what schools are going to rely on. And so one of the primary things that the committee looked at was who can benefit most from distance learning and who might actually be at the large. just disadvantage in the situation of distance learning.
学校提供的线下服务。所以问题在于，如果孩子们将经历远程学习而不是线下学习，哪些孩子从远程学习中受益最多或最少？当远程学习持续很长一段时间时，谁面临的风险最大？这确实需要转向发展心理学文献，以及我们对不同年龄段儿童的学习方式及其所需支持的了解。因此，委员会广泛审视了我们对儿童发展、学术发展、认知发展以及不同年龄段儿童社会情感发展的了解，以及我们对远程学习模式（特别是虚拟学习）的了解，因为我们假设学校将很大程度上依赖这种模式。委员会研究的主要问题之一是，谁能从远程学习中受益最多，而在远程学习的情况下，谁实际上可能处于最大的劣势。
Now, leaving aside, things we know about problems of access, like broadband access and things like that, but just looking developmentally at the question, the committee weighed the ways that students can engage in virtual learning as it relates to their development. So young children in particular are still in the process of developing self-regulation, executive function, all the things that allow you to monitor and check on your own learning. Maintaining attention, diverting your attention back if you get distracted, things like that. Young children are less able to do that than older children. On the whole, certainly there's wide individual differences.
撇开我们已知的接入问题（如宽带接入等）不谈，仅从发展角度来看，委员会权衡了学生参与虚拟学习的方式与其发展之间的关系。特别是年幼的孩子，他们仍处于发展自我调节、执行功能以及所有允许你监控和检查自己学习过程的能力的阶段。保持注意力、在分心时将注意力拉回等。与大孩子相比，年幼的孩子在这方面的能力较弱。总的来说，当然存在广泛的个体差异。
And we talked with Barbara Means, who's at Digital Promise, who's done research on education technology. And she emphasized that particularly for younger children, most often because of those developmental issues, they do better in virtual settings with adult supervision because an adult can help guide their engagement with the technology. They can redirect them if they lose attention. And they can help them do the kinds of things like asking themselves questions about whether they really understood what just happened. So is that somebody at home with them? That's not the teacher necessarily, but it's a parent who's guiding. Correct. If you're using technology in a classroom, it's a teacher, usually, or a teacher's aide. If you're home, it's somebody older than the child. Maybe that's a parent or guardian. Maybe in some cases it's an older sib, but it's someone who can help redirect them. And so the thinking was that young children in particular may be at risk if they're having extended distance learning because it's just harder for them to engage in a serious way over a long period of time with that. medium and given that we know lots of families are going to have caregivers who have to leave
我们与来自Digital Promise的芭芭拉·米恩斯（Barbara Means）进行了交谈，她曾对教育技术进行过研究。她强调，特别是对于年幼的孩子，由于上述发展问题，他们在有成人监督的虚拟环境中表现更好，因为成人可以帮助引导他们与技术互动。如果他们注意力不集中，成人可以引导他们；他们还可以帮助孩子进行自我提问，比如确认他们是否真正理解了刚才发生的事情。所以这是指家里有陪同的人吗？不一定是老师，而是引导他们的家长。没错。如果你在教室里使用技术，通常是老师或助教。如果你在家，那就是比孩子年长的人。可能是家长或监护人。在某些情况下可能是年长的兄弟姐妹，但必须是能帮助引导他们的人。因此，我们的想法是，年幼的孩子如果进行长时间的远程学习，可能会面临风险，因为他们很难在这种媒介下长时间地进行深度参与。考虑到我们知道许多家庭的照护者必须离开
the home. There may not be older children or older children may need to do their own virtual learning. We can't assume that all young children are going to have that support. And so there was a real worry about that. On top of that, there is well-established evidence that for kids in kindergarten through third grade, particularly in reading but also in mathematics, If you have delays in those early grades, and for example, you don't get to a certain level in your reading proficiency, it can have long-term consequences for your academic success. So that the turn of phrase is that up to third grade, you learn to read. After third grade, you read to learn. And so that if you haven't developed some sort of proficiency in reading, by then, you tend to get farther and farther behind.
家。家里可能没有年长的孩子，或者年长的孩子也需要进行自己的虚拟学习。我们不能假设所有年幼的孩子都能得到这种支持。因此，这确实令人担忧。此外，有充分的证据表明，对于幼儿园到三年级的孩子，特别是在阅读和数学方面，如果你在这些早期年级出现滞后，例如，阅读能力没有达到一定水平，可能会对你的学业成功产生长期影响。所以有一句俗语是：三年级之前，你学习阅读；三年级之后，你通过阅读来学习。因此，如果你在那之前没有培养出某种阅读能力，你往往会越来越落后。
and that sort of lack of reading ability early on has actually been linked to dropout rates and things like that. So there was some real concern that, one, these younger kids might not benefit from the distance learning as much. They might need adult supervision or supervision from someone older than them that isn't available. And that the consequences for them would be bigger in terms of the long-term academic outcomes. And finally, the committee then also looked at the evidence on who, most impacted, which of those young children are likely to have the biggest long-term sort of negative consequences? And they're an equity issue emerged where it's pretty clear we already have some socioeconomic differences between kids when they enter school with wealthier children
这种早期阅读能力的缺乏实际上与辍学率等问题有关。因此，人们非常担心：第一，这些年幼的孩子可能无法从远程学习中获得那么多益处。他们可能需要成人或比他们年长的人的监督，而这种监督是不可用的。第二，从长期的学业成果来看，这对他们造成的后果会更严重。最后，委员会还研究了关于谁受影响最大、哪些年幼的孩子最可能产生最大的长期负面后果的证据。这里出现了一个公平问题，很明显，当孩子们进入学校时，我们已经存在一些社会经济差异，富裕家庭的孩子
typically coming in already with some reading skill. Schools sometimes can close that, but there was particular concern that for low income children, they might be sort of get a double hit in the very young children where if they didn't have access to the distance learning to the same level, and then they didn't have the adult support, and then we already know there's some lags that you were going to really create a big equity issue. So what happens around sixth grade where kids are able to engage in distance learning in an effective way? What's going on in their brains that makes it more feasible starting at that age? Well, they're actually over time, and certainly I want to emphasize, again, there are not every kid, but. Right, not having kid. But in general,
通常在入学时就已经具备了一些阅读技能。学校有时可以缩小这种差距，但人们特别担心低收入家庭的孩子，他们可能会在年幼时遭受“双重打击”：如果他们无法获得同等水平的远程学习，又没有成人的支持，而且我们已经知道存在一些滞后，那么这确实会造成巨大的公平问题。那么，六年级左右孩子们能够有效参与远程学习时会发生什么？他们的大脑发生了什么变化，使得从那个年龄开始变得更可行？嗯，实际上随着时间的推移，我再次强调，并非每个孩子都一样，但确实。没错，不是每个孩子。但总的来说，
as you move into middle school and especially into high school, kids are developing what we call executive function, the ability to monitor their own learning, the ability to regulate their own behavior and regulate attention. So it's what we might call metacognition, the ability to kind of look at your own state of knowledge, to understand your memory limitations, to know when your attention is drifting and have strategies for bringing it back. And that develops over time. And starting in middle school and into high school, kids are getting better at that. Certainly, they still have a ways to go. Those of us who know middle schoolers and high schoolers know they're not all great at it, but they're certainly getting better and you see a big difference between, say, a seven-year-old
当你进入初中，尤其是高中时，孩子们正在发展我们所说的执行功能，即监控自己学习的能力，调节自己行为和注意力的能力。这可能被称为元认知，即审视自己知识状态的能力，了解自己记忆的局限性，知道自己的注意力何时漂移并有策略地将其拉回。这是随着时间推移而发展的。从初中到高中，孩子们在这方面做得越来越好。当然，他们还有很长的路要走。我们这些了解初中生和高中生的人都知道，他们并非都擅长此道，但他们确实在进步，而且你可以看到，比如七岁
and a 13-year-old in the ability to do those things. So you mentioned a minute ago about disparities and what happens to children who come from families that don't have the resources to manage their education at home and those who do. So if schools are forced into remote learning, what can they do to address these equity issues? Some of it is purely access, which doesn't go into really the details of learning at all, but it is purely looking at, and schools did a lot of this in spring 2020 with the big closures, providing devices if you knew that kids didn't have them at home, providing in some places, school systems knew that there wasn't good broadband access and they might have done packets, right, instead of online. Some did mobile hotspots. You know, we read about, I'm sure people have read about buses where they put, you know, hot spots on the bus and drove them around or people driving to parking lots, you know, next to a library where they would have. None of that is ideal.
和十三岁在做这些事情的能力上有很大的不同。所以你刚才提到了差异，以及那些来自没有资源在家管理教育的家庭的孩子与那些有资源的孩子之间会发生什么。那么，如果学校被迫进行远程学习，他们能做些什么来解决这些公平问题呢？其中一些纯粹是接入问题，这根本不涉及学习细节，但纯粹是着眼于此。学校在2020年春季大范围关闭时做了很多工作，比如如果你知道孩子们家里没有设备，就提供设备；在某些地方，学校系统知道没有良好的宽带接入，他们可能会提供学习包，而不是在线学习。有些学校提供了移动热点。你知道，我们读到过，我相信人们读到过关于校车的新闻，他们在校车上安装热点并开着它们到处走，或者人们开车到图书馆旁边的停车场，在那里他们会有信号。这些都不是理想的。
But providing good access is one of them. Then there are other things about how you structure the learning. And we didn't go as much into this in the report. we weren't asked these educational questions, but we did refer there's a nice discussion of this that the education trust and digital promise put together, sort of questions to look at and examples of how to provide more equitable digital learning. And some of those things are, for example, not assuming that all kids can do what would be called synchronous learning, where the teacher is engaging in discussion or delivering instructions and you expect all students to be there out of a certain time, but to allow for some asynchronous as well so that you can adjust to family schedules
但提供良好的接入是其中之一。然后还有关于如何构建学习的其他事情。我们在报告中没有深入探讨这一点，我们没有被要求回答这些教育问题，但我们确实提到了这一点，教育信托（Education Trust）和Digital Promise整理了一份很好的讨论，列出了一些需要关注的问题和如何提供更公平的数字学习的例子。其中一些例子是，例如，不要假设所有孩子都能进行所谓的同步学习，即老师在进行讨论或传授指令，并期望所有学生在特定时间都在场，而是允许一些异步学习，这样你就可以适应家庭的时间表，
so that if a parent has to be or a guardian has to be out of a house at a certain time, you might then allow asynchronous so that in the evening when there is an adult, that might be when they can carve out the time to do sort of the dedicated virtual learning. So allowing that kind of flexibility. Creating tasks that don't necessarily have to have an adult or an older sib around to do them. So thinking about not assuming you're going to have the adult support and the background. Those are just a few examples. A lot of what children get from school, face-to-face school, of course, is meeting their social and emotional needs. And some people think that children need to be in school just to be around other children and that distance learning is just
这样如果家长或监护人必须在特定时间离开家，你就可以允许异步学习，这样在晚上有成年人在家时，他们就可以腾出时间进行专门的虚拟学习。所以要允许这种灵活性。创建不需要成年人或年长的兄弟姐妹在场就能完成的任务。所以要考虑到不要假设你会有成人的支持和背景。这些只是几个例子。当然，孩子们从学校、面对面学校获得的大部分东西是满足他们的社会和情感需求。有些人认为孩子们需要去学校只是为了和其他孩子在一起，而远程学习只是
not good for their emotional and mental health. Your report didn't really get into that question. And why not? Did you consider it but just not put it in the report? Yeah, it's a great question. And I will say that the committee did think about even just in terms of learning, the fact that what we know from research on learning is that across all subject areas, the peer to peer learning is really important too. And so that's definitely the case. And that's something you want to build in, even if you're trying to do, even if you're doing virtual. The question of the sort of socio-emotional development and outcomes was a tricky one.
对他们的情感和心理健康不好。你们的报告并没有真正深入探讨这个问题。为什么不呢？你们考虑过但没有把它写进报告吗？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我得说，委员会确实考虑过，即使仅就学习而言，我们从学习研究中知道，在所有学科领域，同伴学习也非常重要。所以这绝对是事实。即使你试图进行虚拟学习，这也是你需要融入的东西。关于社会情感发展和结果的问题是一个棘手的问题。
And the committee heard from some experts who talked about that. But what became difficult was to really look broadly at the literature and get a handle on whether school was the only place where that could definitely be provided. So the notion that it could be that you can support some of that social, emotional, peer interaction through other community organizations and in families and neighborhoods. In addition, there's some important discussions in the literature on schools that indicate that schools aren't always a positive place for all kids all the time. and that you do have some kids who have negative socio-emotional consequences from interactions in the school, like from bullying, or for black children, there's some of the discipline practices in some settings can be harsh and can actually lead to interactions with the criminal justice system at a higher rate than white children. So it was a very, very complicated issue to tease all of that apart and understand what are the broad socio-emotional, consequences for not being in school buildings. And can you make a strong argument that closing school buildings totally eliminates for all kids those positive socio-emotional opportunities?
委员会确实听取了一些专家的意见，他们谈到了这一点。但困难在于真正广泛地审视文献，并弄清楚学校是否是唯一绝对能提供这种支持的地方。所以，这种观点认为，你可能可以通过其他社区组织、家庭和邻里来支持部分社会、情感和同伴互动。此外，文献中关于学校的一些重要讨论表明，学校并不总是对所有孩子来说都是一个积极的地方。确实有一些孩子因为学校里的互动而产生负面社会情感后果，比如欺凌，或者对于黑人儿童来说，在某些环境下的纪律处分可能很严厉，甚至可能导致他们比白人儿童以更高的比率与刑事司法系统产生接触。因此，要理清所有这些并理解不待在学校建筑里对社会情感产生的广泛后果，是一个非常、非常复杂的问题。你能有力地论证关闭学校建筑完全消除了所有孩子获得这些积极社会情感机会的可能性吗？
And the committee, one didn't have time to go into that nuance and wasn't sure that the argument was going to be as strong as it clearly was fairly strong for the academic outcomes. The report makes some specific suggestions about what schools can do to mitigate health risks if they reopen, including providing face masks, enforcing physical distancing, and implementing new cleaning protocols. Which of these are the most important? And are there other steps that schools can be taking? One of the real challenges for the committee was that we don't have a robust evidence based in schools that tells us specifically the differential effectiveness of these different strategies. But based on kind of first principles of transmission, given that the virus is transmitted by droplet, respiratory droplets, and aerosols, it's clear that masks for everyone where possible, teachers particularly, but really it's safest if everyone is wearing them, the physical distancing that we've all heard about and we've all hopefully been practicing, and then eliminating large crowds.
委员会一方面没有时间去深入探讨这种细微差别，也不确定这种论点是否像学术成果那样清晰有力。报告确实就学校重新开放时如何减轻健康风险提出了一些具体建议，包括提供口罩、强制保持身体距离和实施新的清洁规程。这些中哪些最重要？学校还可以采取其他措施吗？委员会面临的真正挑战之一是，我们没有学校方面的强有力证据基础来告诉我们这些不同策略的具体差异化有效性。但基于传播的第一原则，鉴于病毒是通过飞沫、呼吸道飞沫和气溶胶传播的，很明显，在可能的情况下，每个人都戴口罩（特别是老师，但如果每个人都戴口罩，确实是最安全的）、我们都听说过并希望一直在实践的身体距离，以及消除大型集会，
and that just eliminates it's easier to maintain physical distancing without those large crowds and it eliminates the number of opportunities for people to be infected in and large events of infection. Those are key. In addition, there's growing evidence, and this was a real challenge to the committee because emerging discussion that some of these droplets can become aerosolized, meaning very, very tiny and suspended in air, and that evidence was emerging as the committee was doing its work, which is a big challenge. But it looks like there might be some mechanism there,
这更容易在没有大型人群的情况下保持身体距离，并消除了人们在大型感染事件中被感染的机会。这些是关键。此外，越来越多的证据表明，这是一个对委员会的真正挑战，因为新兴的讨论表明其中一些飞沫可以变成气溶胶，意味着非常、非常微小并悬浮在空气中，而这些证据在委员会工作时正在出现，这是一个巨大的挑战。但看起来可能存在某种机制，
which means that you do need to worry about ventilation and air filtration, so that opening doors, opening windows, making sure you have circulation, giving kids time to be outside. In some places, there's even been discussion of outdoor classrooms, which we didn't go into detail in the report, because there's such varying climates in the U.S. and such varying possibility of even doing that. But those are important also.
这意味着你需要担心通风和空气过滤，所以打开门、打开窗户、确保空气流通、给孩子们户外活动的时间。在某些地方，甚至有关于户外教室的讨论，我们没有在报告中详细说明，因为美国的气候差异很大，甚至做到这一点的可能性也各不相同。但这些也很重要。
A really promising strategy is something called cohorting or podding. Pods are what they're sometimes called where you have smaller groups of kids with a single teacher who move together during the day, eat in the room together. And there are sort of two different pieces to that. One is that it limits the number of different people they're all exposed to and limits the risk that way. It also means that if you do have someone in that pod getting sick, it limits the spread so that then you're not needing to sort of close down a whole building because you've limit it to that pot. It's easier to do the sort of contact tracing. And so that's another
一个非常有前景的策略叫做“分组”或“豆荚”（podding）。有时被称为“豆荚”，即你有一小群孩子和一个老师，他们白天在一起活动，在房间里一起吃饭。这其中有两个不同的部分。一是它限制了他们接触到的不同人数，从而限制了风险。这也意味着，如果你那个小组里确实有人生病了，它限制了传播，这样你就不需要关闭整个建筑，因为你把它限制在那个小组里了。更容易进行接触者追踪。所以这是另一个
promising strategy. So you must have been well into the study, in fact, probably done by the time the study came out from South Korea finding that children younger than 10 transmit COVID to others much less often than adults do, but the risk is not zero, and that those from ages 10 to 19 spread the virus at least as well as adults do. You sort of magically hit that point by saying K through five, right? I mean, you didn't have this information, but it just turns out you appear to be very prescient. Yes, yes, we're very lucky. No, that study came out afterwards, and I must say was relieved that it didn't say, for example, six-year-olds are just as contagious as the older kids, for sure. There was also one that came out after our study, a study from Israel, where
有前景的策略。所以你们在研究进行到很深的时候，实际上可能在研究发布时已经完成了，来自韩国的研究发现，10岁以下的儿童传播新冠病毒给其他人的频率远低于成年人，但风险并非为零，而10到19岁的人传播病毒的能力至少和成年人一样。你们通过说K到5年级，神奇地击中了那个点，对吧？我的意思是，你们没有这些信息，但结果证明你们似乎非常有先见之明。是的，是的，我们非常幸运。不，那项研究是在我们之后出来的，我必须说，我很欣慰它没有说，例如，六岁的孩子和年龄较大的孩子一样具有传染性。在我们研究之后还有一项研究，来自以色列的研究，其中
if I remember right, they were pointing particularly at the middle school students as being somewhat responsible for spread. And there it was a partly compliance with the protocols so that the younger children were more compliant. The older children maybe understood better why they should be doing it. And the middle schoolers were the ones who they had maybe less consistent following of the protocols. So this might be beyond the scope of the report, but some school districts are giving parents a choice. So where I live, for example, which is Fairfax County, Virginia, they've decided to let parents select between a two-day-a-week-in-person hybrid learning model or full-time remote learning. How should parents decide what should they take into consideration
如果我没记错的话，他们特别指出初中生在某种程度上要对传播负责。在那里，这部分是由于对规程的遵守情况，年幼的孩子更顺从。年龄较大的孩子可能更理解为什么要这样做。而初中生可能是那些对规程执行得不那么一致的人。所以这可能超出了报告的范围，但一些学区正在给家长选择权。比如我住的地方，弗吉尼亚州费尔法克斯县，他们决定让家长在每周两天面对面混合学习模式或全职远程学习之间进行选择。家长应该如何决定？他们应该考虑什么
when they're looking at an option like this? This is a really tough question, and it does go beyond the report. I'm willing to make some comments on it, but I have to stress this isn't in the report itself. This is sort of a discussion of what you might consider. Okay, that's fair. Based on my judgment, yeah. One is your own child. In many cases, you'll have had an experience. You'll have had an experience with the virtual learning in spring 2020 or distance learning, and you can make some judgments about how well they did. It's important to keep in mind that what happened in spring was not what any school system would plan. They got no lead time for planning. They did not have a chance to put an infrastructure in place, nor do the professional development that you'd really want to do.
当他们面对这样的选择时？这是一个非常棘手的问题，确实超出了报告的范围。我愿意对此发表一些评论，但我必须强调这不在报告本身中。这只是对你可能考虑的事情的讨论。好的，这很公平。基于我的判断，是的。一是你自己的孩子。在许多情况下，你会有过经验。你在2020年春季有过虚拟学习或远程学习的经验，你可以对他们做得如何做出一些判断。重要的是要记住，春天发生的事情不是任何学校系统会计划的。他们没有得到任何规划的提前期。他们没有机会建立基础设施，也没有进行你真正想做的专业发展。
So the distance and virtual learning in the coming year will probably be quite different, but you may have gotten a sense of how well your child did, and that might dictate how much you think your individual child could benefit from the face-to-face. The other thing I would do as a parent is ask, on those two days, what are the mitigation strategies you're using? Are you going to be asking everyone where possible to wear masks? How are you going to be implementing physical distancing? What's the ventilation like? So asking the questions about the key strategies. And we actually in chapter five of our report, we kind of discuss them and lay them out, and there's actually a table, table 5-1, that summarizes them. And I might as a parent just look at that table and think, okay, what questions do I want to ask about what's going to happen on those two days if I'm choosing to send my kids in person?
因此，来年的远程和虚拟学习可能会有很大不同，但你可能已经了解了你的孩子做得如何，这可能会决定你认为你的孩子能从面对面学习中受益多少。作为家长，我会做的另一件事是问，在那两天，你们正在使用什么缓解策略？你们会要求每个人在可能的情况下戴口罩吗？你们将如何实施身体距离？通风情况如何？所以要询问关于关键策略的问题。我们实际上在报告的第五章中讨论并列出了它们，实际上有一个表，表5-1，总结了它们。作为家长，我可能会看看那个表，想，好的，如果我选择让我的孩子亲自去学校，我想问关于那两天会发生什么的问题是什么？
The other thing is there are some realities to different family situations. And it could be that both caregivers or one caregiver must work outside the home. And then there's another layer of thinking, which is how am I going to juggle this? Is it easier for me to juggle my work? And whatever if the student is in the school for a couple of days, that's a reasonable factor to have to think about also. It's our reality right now. So you had epidemiologists and public health experts on your podcast. panel, but you didn't come up with a set recommendation of area caseloads for when it's safe for
另一件事是，不同的家庭情况存在一些现实。可能是两个照护者或一个照护者必须在户外工作。然后还有另一层思考，那就是我该如何兼顾这一切？如果学生在学校待几天，我兼顾工作是否更容易？这也是一个合理的考虑因素。这是我们现在的现实。所以你们的播客小组里有流行病学家和公共卫生专家，但你们没有提出关于何时安全重新开放学校的区域病例数建议。为什么你们没有解决这个问题？这是一个很好的问题。在报告发布后的一些媒体报道中确实提到了这一点。原因之一是，在理解什么阈值是有意义的过程中，需要考虑的许多因素是非常本地化的。例如，医疗基础设施的强度。你有多少床位？你的人口有多脆弱？你知道有多少人在户外工作，而不是能够远程办公，社区之间不会有那么多的接触？因此，人们觉得很难设定一个在所有社区都能真正奏效的单一阈值。社区可能有不同的价值观
schools to reopen. Why did you not address that? It's a great question. It was actually raised in some of the press coverage of the report after it came out. And one of the reasons is that so many of the factors that need to be taken into account in understanding what threshold makes sense are very local. For example, the strength of the health care infrastructure. How much bed space do you have? How vulnerable is your population? How many people do you know are working outside the home versus are going to be able to be teleworking and there won't be as much contact across the community? And so there was a feeling that it was very difficult to set a single threshold that would really work across all communities. And communities might have different values
以及对承担风险的不同意愿，无论是在公共卫生方面还是在教育方面。因此，委员会确实认为，在对话中需要公共卫生和流行病学的观点和科学。但同时要考虑社区的价值观和需求。因此，委员会只是觉得，如果不权衡不同社区的这些不同方面，就很难设定一个单一的阈值。这在某种程度上说明了这可能不是一个一次性的决定。所以学校可以在一个地区重新开放，然后因为感染率的情况决定必须关闭。
and different willingness to take risk, either on the public health side or on the education side. And so the committee really thought there was a sense that you'd need the public health and epidemiology perspectives and science in the conversation. But considering at the same time the values and the needs of the community. And so the committee just felt that it was very difficult to set a single threshold without being able to weigh those different aspects of individual communities. That kind of speaks to the possibility that this might not be a one-time-only decision. So schools could reopen in one area and then decide that they have to close because of what's
你认为谁应该参与这些关闭和重新开放的决定？学校和社区如何为此做好准备？这实际上是报告中的强有力建议之一，即在决策过程中形成某种联盟，从社区的各种利益相关者中汲取意见。当然，关键是教育领导者和公共卫生领导者，以及具备传染病知识的人。
happening with their infection rate. Who do you think should be involved in those closing and re-reactual? reopening decisions and how can schools and communities prepare for that? So that was actually one of the strong recommendations in the report, which was that there be some kind of coalition formed that is part of the decision-making process that draws from a variety of stakeholders in the community. Of course, key are leaders in education and leaders in public health and with knowledge of infectious disease.
这些决定极其复杂。正如我提到的，它们需要权衡风险，这需要公共卫生和流行病学的专业知识，以及教育方面的专业知识。这不太可能存在于一个人身上，对吧？甚至学校里的一群人身上。此外，你希望社区得到代表，学校工作人员、家长、潜在的社区领袖和商业领袖。并建立某种联盟或工作组。然后非常清楚这些阈值是什么。所以即使委员会没有明确说明阈值，
These decisions are incredibly complex. And as I mentioned, they require the weighing of risks that require expertise in public health and epidemiology as well as expertise in education. It's unlikely that lives in one person, right? Or even one set of people in the school. In addition, you want the community represented, the school staff, the parents, potentially community leaders and business leaders. And creating some kind of coalition or task force. and then being very clear on what those thresholds are. So even though the committee didn't necessarily say the thresholds,
如果某种联盟能非常清楚地说明，我们将在寻找什么来决定学校是否需要再次关闭，这对社区非常有帮助，对吧？我们的阈值是什么？或者如果我们决定只从K-2开始，我们将进行谨慎的开放，只服务于最年幼的孩子，如果情况看起来在绿色范围内，我们可能会开放更多，那会是什么样子？这对于社区来说需要非常清楚，这样他们才能理解并看到数据是如何表明应该做出什么决定的。
it's very helpful to a community. If some kind of coalition can make it very clear, here's what we'll be looking for to decide whether schools need to close again, right? Here's what our thresholds are going to be. Or if we decide to only start with K2, we're going to do a cautious opening and just serve the youngest children, And here's what it might need to look like if it looks like things are kind of in the green and we might open up more. That just needs to be very clear for a community so that their understanding and can see how the data are indicating what decisions should be made.
但委员会绝对认为这是一个迭代的过程，因为正如我们已经看到的，你可能会在不同地点出现爆发。而且有一个非常具有挑战性的计算，我们想在可能的情况下开放，但有时这种开放意味着你会看到爆发，你只是想知道你将如何应对不断变化的比率。所以你为家长提供了关于是否送孩子回学校面对面学习的建议。你对行政人员和学校官员的决定有什么建议？他们正在挣扎，没有太多时间来下定决心或落实报告中建议的一些变化。
But the committee absolutely thinks it's an iterative process because as we've already seen, you can get flare-ups on different locations. and there's this really challenging calculus of we want to open up, you know, as we can, but sometimes that opening up is going to mean you see a flare, and you just want to know how you're going to respond to the changing rates. So you've offered some tips for parents in deciding whether to send their children back to in-person school or not. What's your advice for administrators and school officials for their decision? They're struggling and they don't have a lot of time to make up their minds or to put in place some of the changes that they might need that are suggested in this report.
他们如何才能既迅速又聪明地前进？我们强调，委员会在建议中强调，要确保与该地区的公共卫生专家建立伙伴关系，以便决策能得到公共卫生最佳建议的指导。我们实际上指导各州确保所有学区都能获得公共卫生专业知识。你可以想象，像华盛顿特区、波士顿或旧金山这样的一些地区，该地区有许多机构，聚集了公共卫生专家，以及通常非常强大的地方公共卫生办公室。但全国其他地区，特别是农村地区的公共卫生办公室资金不足。可能没有那种
How can they move forward expeditiously but smartly? We emphasize, the committee emphasizes and the recommendations to really make sure there's a partnership with the public health experts in the area so that the decision is informed by the best advice from public health. And we actually direct states to make sure that all districts have access to the public health expertise. You might imagine there are some areas like Washington, D.C. or Boston or San Francisco, with lots of institutions in the area with a concentration of public health experts, as well as the local public health offices, which often are going to be very strong. But there's other parts of the country where the public health. offices in rural areas especially haven't been well funded. And there may not be that kind of
专业知识。我们指导各州确保学区能够获得这些知识。所以第一点是迅速从公共卫生和传染病专家那里获得意见，以便你以知晓社区传播性质的方式做出这些决定。此外，他们可以查看你正在考虑的缓解策略，并提供一些建议。如果这是你考虑在学校实施身体距离的方式，这有意义吗？基于传染病专家对传播的说法，这会奏效吗？查看我们关于需要实施的一系列缓解策略的建议，将最大的权重放在建议中确定的那组策略上。
expertise. And we direct states to make sure that districts have access to that. So that one would be quickly get the input from the public health and infectious disease specialists so that you're making these decisions in a way that's informed by knowledge of the nature of community spread. And also they could look at the mitigation strategies that you're considering and provide some advice on. If this is the way you're thinking of implementing physical distancing in your school, does this make sense? Is this going to work based on what an infectious disease specialist sort of has to say about transmission? Looking at our recommendations about the suite of mitigation strategies that need to be implemented, putting the greatest weight, on the set that are identified in the recommendation.
CDC确实呼吁采取一套做法，但关于其可行性和投资回报似乎存在混合证据，那就是体温筛查和症状筛查，这给每天早上带人进入学校增加了巨大的实际挑战。而且从证据中不清楚这样做有什么回报，特别是当无症状传播变得越来越明显时，
There is one set of practices that the CDC does call for, but there seem to be mixed evidence about its sort of practicality and return on investment, and that's the temperature screening and symptom screening, which adds a huge layer of practical challenge to bringing people into the school each morning. And it's just not clear from the evidence what the return is on doing that, especially as it becomes more clear that there's asymptomatic
这意味着可能会有人在没有发烧、症状极轻的情况下进入学校，但他们具有传染性。所以一定要确保家庭理解，如果孩子表现出任何迹象，或者你强烈怀疑你的家庭有接触史，最好让孩子待在家里。同样，制定政策，让员工在感到不适或知道有接触史时可以安心待在家里。所以我们在第五章讨论缓解策略时，也讨论了创造一种每个人都致力于集体保护彼此健康的文化，这也是学校需要设定的重要部分。所以你有程序，但随后创造每个人都能理解它们、理解为什么他们要这样做的方式，
transmission, which means that there could be people coming into the school without fevers with minimal symptoms who are contagious. And so definitely making sure families understand, keep kids home if they're showing any signs or if you strongly suspect there's been exposure in your family, better to keep kids home. Similarly, creating policies so that staff can feel okay about staying home if they are feeling sick or know there's been an exposure. So we have some discussion in our chapter 5 where we discuss the mitigation strategies, also about the idea that creating a culture where there's sort of everyone is committed to collectively protecting each other's, health is part of what's important to set in a school as well. So you have the procedures, but then creating ways where everyone understands them, understands why they're doing them,
这是一种相互尊重，并以积极的方式努力保持彼此安全，包括围绕以下方面的政策：你知道，在疫情期间你不会因为全勤而获得奖励，因为那实际上不会发出你想要的信号。好观点，好观点。嗯，这真的很有趣。施万·格鲁伯博士，我非常感谢你今天抽出时间与我们交谈。谢谢。这是我的荣幸。谢谢。美国心理学会的网站上有资源和提示单，可帮助应对疫情。请访问APA.org。你也可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集，你可以在
and sort of it's a mutual respect in and trying to keep each other safe in a positive way, including policies around, you know, you don't get the award for perfect attendance during a pandemic because that's not actually going to send the signal that you want. Good point, good point. Well, this has been really interesting. Dr. Schwanengruber, I really appreciate you're taking the time to talk to us today. Thank you. It's a pleasure. Thank you. The American Psychological Association has resources and tipsheets available on our website for help in navigating the pandemic. Visit us at APA.org. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org, and you can subscribe to our
Apple、Stitcher或几乎任何你获取播客的地方订阅我们的播客。如果你有关于未来剧集的评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@APA.org。那是speakingofpsychology，全部连在一起，在APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音响工程师是克里斯·康迪（Chris Kondy）。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
podcast on Apple, Stitcher, or pretty much anywhere you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound engineer is Chris Kondy. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在Apple、Stitcher或您获取播客的任何地方收听我们的节目。如果您对未来的剧集有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。即speakingofpsychology（全部连在一起）@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Weinerman制作。我们的音响工程师是Chris Kondy。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。